if you look at for example curtis yarvin
there's a tremendous amount of interest
is eric gonna speak to curtis yarvin
curtis yarman says many interesting
things and he says many horrible stupid
things very provocative
and i don't i haven't i haven't invited
him onto the portal
but i haven't said i will never invite
him on to the portal
we are all in a difficult position
that's what i'm saying
you're making it kind of i think it's a
much more difficult task
that and burden will carry as people who
have conversations because
courtesy iron is a good example how much
work do i have to put in reading
curtis's work to really
understand talk about the problem of
curtis jarvin yes because i think it's
probably
illustrative there's this big question
is why does somebody who says such
stupid ass things listened to by so many
people
very smart people people who are part of
our daily lives discuss
curtis yarvin in hush tones now let's do
a question
my belief is that curtis yarvin has made
a number of
very interesting provocative points and
they associate curtis yarvin as the
person who has made these points
and they treat the completely asinine
stuff that he says that's super
dangerous
as well that's curtis
right right they give him the credit for
he he's he's kind of like
sorry to use the term first principles
deep thinker about
in some way some in some space about the
world
yeah but as a result we don't actually
know
why curtis yarvin is knocking around
so many silicon valley luminaries lives
what's see see you said that he said a
lot of sni stupid stuff and that's the
sense i got from a few things i've read
not just about it this is not just like
wikipedia stuff
is he he's a little like i've said
before
he seems to be careless i don't think
he's care no no it's like jim watson
jim watson wants to say very provocative
things in order to prove that he's free
it's not question of careless he enjoys
yeah the freedom to say these things
yeah and the key point is is that
there's i expect
something more of curtis i expect that
if somebody is
insightful about all sorts of things up
to that point
that they're going to have enough care
now i for example make this point
repeatedly that vaccines are not 100
safe most people who have an idea that
anybody is an anti-vaxxer should be
silenced
are in a position where they they they
probably don't say vaccines are 100 say
but
you keep finding that statement over and
over again like believe all women
vaccines are 100 safe climate science is
settled science
whatever this mountain bailey is where
you make extraordinarily
vapid blanket claims and then you
retreat into something well defund the
pull you know we don't want
no more police actually just means we
want the police to
not take on mental health duties
we've come up with an incredibly
disingenuous society
and what i'm claiming is is that i might
talk to curtis yarvin
but i have really very little interest
to talk to a guy
who seems to be kind of giddy about who
makes good slaves and who makes bad
slaves
it's like why do i want to do that on
the portal
one first of all because just as you
said
that's not curtis's main thing he has a
lot of ideas and
what i've read of him which is not a
huge amount
is there's he's very thoughtful about
the way this world
works and on top of that he's an
important historical figure
in the birth and the development of the
alt-right or what would be called our
right
the new reaction yeah and there's so
he's in
just an important intellectual and so
it makes sense to talk to him the
question is how much work do you put in
well this is the issue of fugu i'm not a
chef
that necessarily can serve that fugu
so you have you have a puffer fish you
can eat the puffer fish
you can you can get a kind of a tingly
sensation on your tongue
if you get a little bit of the poison
organ but my point is i don't know how
to serve
curtis yarvin yeah so that in fact i'm
not worried
about what happens and i believe that if
somebody else was a student
of the new reactionary movement that
person might be in a better position to
host curtis yarwin
you